[Music]
Hi Well lookie lookie she is the perfect
fit I promise did she even see you she
was about
to what are you doing don't do
this no no
no
[Music]
hi oh God
starts this is just so exciting what is
happening well that's a perfectly
understandable question given them I'm
an if get it imaginary
friend our kids grew up so we need new
ones you could save all of us all of who
and don't say if
let him say it or I think his head may
actually
explode
[Music]
fine thank you you ready for this like
myON there's no telling who's behind
that door
today we have to help them yes we
do if I
can not going to ask you again put some
pants on you're freaking everyone
out starting to see why I live
alone
Che kind of a kid creates an invisible
[Music]
if don't uh don't don't look him in the
eye which one you know damn well which
one thanks for doing this it really
means a whole
lot